honoring six decades of educating valley
students with a musical tribute in
today's what's cool at school
las vegas day school was founded by jack
and helen dossler in 1961 with
27 students in a one-room rented
schoolhouse
six decades later the school educates
800 kids a year on a 17-acre campus
it was time to celebrate
students paid tribute to the school's
60th anniversary with a virtual and
vocal thank you
[Music]
led by their musical theater director 40
students spanning across grades saying
some things never change from frozen two
all of a sudden they come out of their
shells and
i'm just amazed every time i do an
audition at how
many kids are just little
stars in the making it made me feel
really
happy that it's all together or it's
like
kind of like a wholesome feeling and my
classmates were really excited
and we're all getting older and wiser
that's why we
rely on certain certainties
the goal was to honor how lvds has
persevered through a pandemic
and also thrived through 60 years in las
vegas
educating thousands i also wanted the
children the kids that were
actually doing the singing to understand
the importance of
how special it was for
us to have come all of this way it also
gave
musical theater kids who have been
silenced and sidelined for a full
calendar year to sing out this was so
special too because
i hadn't had a chance all year to see
any of my musical theater kids
and so this was a great opportunity for
us to
you know let them use their creative
side it's so important
i really love all the work that goes
into it at the end
i love how everyone kind of joins
together
and i just really love doing it it's
kind of one of my passions
being a musical theater teacher isn't
about creating more
singers and dancers in the world it's
about creating a more well-rounded
child the reaction beyond expectations
well i got lots and lots of thank yous
and
you know lots of tears and and
and everyone's just so joyful
you know i think that teachers
especially
um took it to heart
[Music]
and that's what's cool at school if you
know something that's cool at school
head to eight news now dot com click on
cool at school under the community tab
or send your email to cool at school at
eight newsnow dot com